hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
and in this video I'm gonna give away a
three thousand pound gift credited to
somebody in the next couple weeks or so
[Music]
I'm really tired up here at people's
excuses man I'm tired of hearing people
say I'm too young I'm too old I'm too
broke I live a way too far my country's
no good I'm just tired of it when I
started out in property guess what I
could have come up with many reasons why
I couldn't do it I was 17 years old so
I'm too young I couldn't get a mortgage
I was skimmed had no money I wasn't from
a family of property investors or ball
of a silver spoon in my mouth
jeez it was 2008 when I started the
brink of a massive recession a global
recession that could have been so many
reasons why I'm like I'm out I can't do
this
but you know what when I started out 17
I didn't even list the reasons why I
couldn't instead I listed the reasons
why I could instead I'm thinking
unhealthy I'm hungry to succeed I'm from
a good family that support me and
believe in me there's free training
around his seminars and programs and I
can I can go to you for free I'm living
in England which is a great country I'm
prepared to do whatever it takes I
listed the reasons as to what I can do
this I'm thinking if anyone can do it I
can do it here's why no listed those
reasons and I'm gonna give you a
challenge in a minute but firstly I
believe that when you do that when you
list the reasons why you can instead of
listing the reasons why you can't when
you list what's what you've got going
for you not what you've got going
against you what happens is number one
it makes you more attractive more
attractive as a person more attractive
as a joint venture partner but secondly
it makes you a hundred times probably a
thousand times more likely to succeed so
as I want you to succeed here's your
challenge I want you to write a list of
all the things that you have going for
you all the reasons why you can and why
you will succeed only to list as many as
you can and then I want you to post that
list as a comment on this YouTube video
if you list lots and lots and lots of
reasons but they're not real reasons and
I think they're a bit weak or a bit
stupid or irrelevant then maybe we'll
take some off but the person that can
list the most reason
I'm gonna be crediting a 3,000 pound
gift to you and you'll be able to use
that 3000 pound credit to any of my
training programs which is going to mean
that you're gonna be on your journey to
financial freedom and with a can-do
mindset and the training you're gonna
carry so I'm looking forward to making
someone financially free last year I
made 52 people financially for it this
year I'm trying to double it and make
one hundred and four financially free so
far we are in this 70s it's gonna happen
so comment below list your reasons and
let's do this
[Music]
you
[Music]